so yesterday after we learned uh about
the death
of rush limbaugh radical right-wing
radio host who celebrated the death of
ruth bader ginsburg
would celebrate the deaths of aids
victims that rush limbaugh
died yesterday at age 70 of lung cancer
donald trump appeared on fox news during
the day in advance of his nighttime
interviews on oan newsmax and fox news
trump called into
fox news during the day sort of to
eulogize
rush limbaugh but it was a very strange
appearance
and uh it was self-centered and
it was rambling and it was everything
that at this point we would expect from
donald trump so let's jump right into it
he is succumbed to tears and i was
curious what did he know was coming
so i did tell him beforehand because we
didn't
have the uh really the the
power of not doing it you know rush was
very sick at the time
he was at a hospital in boston and i
didn't want to do the surprise thing
uh i wish i wish i could have done that
but we really didn't have that
uh that that uh power of doing it
because he
had it was a very difficult thing for
him to come
into washington from where he was and he
did it
and there was questions as to whether or
not he was just a very brave guy he was
amazing and he came in and it was
as he told me it was the greatest honor
of his life and everybody in the room
uh you know you're talking about the
republicans and the democrats yet half
of that room went
crazy you remember the evening well i'm
sure it was very unique moment
yeah in our country's history in a sense
because of who russia is but
halfway just absolutely crazy the other
half sat
totally dead silent but a hundred
percent of that room
respected rush so complete delusions of
grandeur
of course it was a great moment in our
country's history
when a radical right-wing radio host got
a medal from donald trump basically just
a reward for sucking up to donald trump
if that's a notable moment in american
history
when rush limbaugh degraded the meaning
of the presidential medal of freedom
well really it was trump who degraded
the meaning of it
and the value by awarding it to rush
limbaugh if that is a notable
moment in american history it says
something very sad about the country now
i don't believe that obviously there are
many notable moments in american history
trump handing the medal of freedom to a
right-wing radio host
because the hit radio host supported
trump not exactly ranking high
in uh in in moments of american history
and
of course that's why donald trump likes
rush limbaugh
because rush supported donald trump and
it's not true uh we heard in trump in
trump's hannity interview which we'll
look at tomorrow
trump repeated the same line this line
of
democrats respected rush limbaugh no
they didn't
rush limbaugh did disgusting and
depraved things on air
he attacked women he attacked gays he
attacked you know just people on the
left in general
he gleefully he was gleeful when ruth
bader ginsburg died he would
celebrate the deaths of aids patients
during the 90s what
democrats didn't respect rush limbaugh
what on earth is trump talking about but
let's continue
it was a unique guy and he was a he
became a friend of mine you know i
didn't know rush
at all i had essentially never met rush
and then when we came down the escalator
he
liked my rather controversial speech i
made that speech that was a little bit
on the controversial side and he loved
it
and he was without ever having met him
or talked to him or you know had lunch
with him and
asked him he was with me right from the
beginning
and he liked what i said and he agreed
with what i said
and he was just a great gentleman great
great man
and of course that's what this is all
about
rush was with trump to trump that's all
that matters trump doesn't so much
trump often talks about my friends
he doesn't really have friends he has
yes men
and sycophants who he allows to remain
around him
for as long as they remain yes men and
sycophants that's what donald trump has
and that's how donald trump's
relationships work that's how he
evaluates other people
trump then uses rush limbaugh's death
to repeat the long debunked lies
about the election that trump actually
won and
that rush believed it harris what did
rush limbaugh tell you
after the election of november 3rd what
were those conversations like
well rush thought we won and so do i by
the way i i think we won by
substantially uh and rush thought we won
and uh he thought it was over at 10
o'clock 10 30 it was over and a lot of
other people feel that way too but rush
felt that way strongly
and many people do many professionals do
and i don't think that could have
happened to a democrat
you would have had you would have had
riots going all over
the place if that happened to a democrat
we don't have the same support
in the at certain levels of the
republican system
but we have great people as republicans
of course
that was russia's big thing calling
trump up and saying
sir they stole it from you joe biden
didn't really win
and trump going directly into his
election fraud
talking points there repeating all the
same stuff what a great coincidence
right that rush limbaugh thought the
exact same thing so there's donald
trump's
initial sort of bizarre eulogy of rush
limbaugh
he supported me and he agreed the
election was stolen
so he was great well said sir really
nicely done and tomorrow we're going to
look at
uh donald trump's interview with sean
hannity where he actually it's not like
urgent so i don't feel the need to get
to it today we don't have time
but tomorrow i do want to look into it
because there's some interesting stuff
about 2024
um oh some interesting anecdotes so
tomorrow night we will look or tomorrow
on tomorrow's podcast rather we will
look at last night's interview that
donald trump did
with sean hannity uh in the meantime
we'll have to leave it there for today
much to the dismay but also pleasure of
different people in our audience
one of our sponsors is privacy a free
service that protects your credit and
debit card i use privacy every time i
buy something online
i installed the app on my phone and the
privacy desktop browser extension
now when i pay for anything privacy
autofills a virtual
credit card number the money's taken out
of my bank account i don't have to give
out my real card number or banking info
to anyone
you can create and delete the virtual
cards anytime
i especially love it for free trials
because i can destroy the virtual card
number
as soon as i give it to the company and
i know i won't be charged in the future
privacy also has a feature called shared
cards
which makes it easy to split payments
with friends parents can manage a
virtual card for their kid
with spending limits businesses can
manage virtual cards
for employees to use for company
expenses there are premium plans
available but privacy's regular service
is totally free to use
and right now they'll give you five
dollars just for signing up when you go
to privacy.com
pacman the link is underneath this video